Grace Van Dean who is one of the
actresses in stranger things
just came out and explained why she's
quitting Hollywood or at least taking a
break from Hollywood
and it's it's one of the most dignified
videos I've seen out of Hollywood in
years
turning down acting projects and
deciding to stream more but the fact of
the matter is the last few projects I've
worked on
I didn't have the best experiences one
of the last movies I did one of the
producers asked me to
like he hired a girl that was he was
sleeping with and then he had her ask me
to have a threesome with them
so like that's my boss
and so I don't really want to be
pressured to have threesomes with my
boss and so I'm having a new job now
which is similar to my old job but it's
a little bit different good honor
good honor
this is a reminder that integrity
has a cost to it
there are going to be all sorts of
Temptations in life to give up your
integrity to trade your integrity for a
little bit more fame or a little bit
more money or whatever
a little more convenience a little more
ease and she says no and so she's giving
up acting projects because she doesn't
want to take a ride on the casting couch
some people are saying well
she shouldn't have to pay the cost of
that Integrity this this Dirtbag
producer he should be held accountable
yeah he should
totally
he should wouldn't it were so simple
that's not the way Hollywood works
don't look at us conservatives it's not
the conservatives who run Hollywood okay
that's that's not the way Hollywood
works that's not the way Hollywood has
ever worked
there's risk of corruption in all
Industries but especially show business
because the promise of Fame is so
tempting and so uh precious to so many
people and because the the commodity
that you are selling in Show Business is
yourself is your body
so it's no surprise that that commodity
is traded in the back rooms even as it's
traded on camera as well
and she knew that and so
Grace Van Deen could try to restart the
metoo movement the metoo movement was
always bogus it was always just a a PR
stunt
not not the women who were complaining
about the abuse but all of the Hollywood
Dirtbag men said oh Ahi for she I'm with
her or I'm the time's up me too they're
all the ones perpetrating it they had no
intention of changing their behavior it
was all totally fake
and so instead of Grace vanity saying
I'm gonna wait for reality to be
different than it has always been in
this dirty town
I'm just gonna I'm not gonna do it if
that's the cost of being a big star in
Hollywood I'm not going to do it I'll go
do something else
good honor
this is the consequence
of a theme that we've been talking about
for the past week which is feminism in
the sexual Revolution
feminism says women and men should be
treated exactly the same they're
indiscernible woman needs man like fish
needs a bicycle
well consequence of that is men are not
going to treat women with a special care
they're going to treat women the way
they'd treat men with the same kind of
roughness that they would treat men and
that's that's no good because men and
women really are different the sexual
Revolution is a consequence of feminism
says oh sex it's it can be totally
casual doesn't mean anything and so
sex is going to be traded as a casual
thing in Hollywood it's a direct
consequence of this and rather than try
to change the whole world Grace Grace
Van Deen says
I'm out see ya
good honor very very impressive
I think it's irrefutable though
all this sexual Revolution stuff
stemming from feminism has not succeeded
at what it promised to do which is make
everybody happier it has made everybody
more miserable I gave this talk in
Buffalo on Thursday
thousand people showed up even though
the room was relatively small it's only
about a 300 person room it's probably
500 protesters so even just the
protesters wouldn't have been able to
fit into the room and it was a fairly
modest speech on the history of feminism
and how it pertains to political
correctness wokeness leftism
relatively dry speech but people got so
wound up about it there was a debriefing
at the gender Institute of the
University of Buffalo
debriefing by these professors and
students to to
work through the Stress and Anxiety
caused by my campus lecture
this was a really emotional ex so I
think I'm gonna go back a step and say
it was an awful experience
um and that probably the worst part of
it
was the absolute Glee that some of the
audience took honestly I have not seen
such Glee except maybe in you know Nazi
like propaganda you know like it was
really something the long lines were
engineered
um to create fear so there wasn't like
that's not
free and public discourse that's a
performance okay
so much there first of all the long
lines were engineered to create fear
the the long lines were a result of lots
of people showing up to the event
they weren't engineered there there was
a door to the event and people were
allowed in until it the room was filled
and when you are waiting to get into a
show or a lecture or any public space
you wait in a line it was the fear
the long lines of the fear and and but
if you did make it into the room the
worst part was the Glee people actually
liked what this awful man said and the
only time I've seen Glee like this was
in Nazi propaganda
if your only reference point
for Glee
is Nazi propaganda
something has gone seriously wrong in
your life if you if you can't when you
think of Glee you don't think of my
child's birthday party the the look on
my loved one's face as we watched the
sunset if you know you you're the only
gleeful experience that you can think of
is a Nazi propaganda movie
your life does not have enough Glee okay
you need to go outside and touch grass
and I don't know go watch a movie or
something you know take a walk on the
beach anything anything get get
something in your life that is not
totally misery inducing
but unfortunately
these people
live their lives in in accordance with
ideas that are not conducive to their
flourishing I mean that's the whole
point of the talk I said these ideas
such as feminism
promise to make you happy and then every
measure we have of it shows that they
have not made you happy they've made you
more and more miserable so if you
if you suffer at any point in your life
well that's just life life has suffering
to it okay and you're gonna have bad
days and the rain falls on the just and
the unjust alike and that's just part of
it
but if you are
constantly miserable
if you never ever feel Glee and someone
else exhibiting happiness causes you
pain
that's on you something something is
wrong in your mind
and you need to change your mind a
little bit or else you're going to
continue living a very miserable life
it's music Monday baby
the rest of the show continues now you
don't want to miss it become a member
right now if you're not already a member
the leware.com Knowles use code Knowles
at checkout for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]
thank you